Hey traders, it's Mike here, and in this
video, I'm going to take you through my
5-second footprint read, which is
basically my entire
order flow exhaustion entry model. I'm
not joking, 5 seconds. It takes me about
5 seconds to know if there is a trade or
not. You know, and after 20 years of
trading at places like JP Morgan and
Commerzbank, I've boiled my entire order
flow exhaustion entry model down to one
single read on the footprint, you know,
at the exact moment when I know buyers
or sellers have run out of ammunition.
So, today is uh you know, May 20th, and
you know, it was an interesting day
today because, you know, we had some
news coming out of the Middle East that,
you know, maybe we're close to some
peace talks. And for most of the
morning, you know, the market had been
uh pretty quiet. Uh just really quick,
you know, this is the S&P's. You know,
we opened up here in the cash, and we
just sort of went sideways for the most
part. Then we started to rally and and
make new highs. And up here at this high
of the day, we had a nice exhaustion
print. And it only takes me, you know,
just a few seconds to take a look at
this and understand what is going on.
So, what is actually happening here? So,
we are going up to these highs here,
making new highs. That's this green line
up in here. All right? And
as we are going up, right? We got
positive delta, big positive delta on
this bar right here.
2436 positive delta. That means, you
know, the net difference between
aggressive buyers and aggressive sellers
was
uh aggressive buyers beat the passive
sell uh aggressive buyers beat the
aggressive sellers by 2,436
contracts.
And then we make a new high, and we've
got negative delta minus 145. We make
another new high,
negative delta of 373. So, what's taking
place? You know, we got the nice
aggressive buying going into the high,
make a new high, but on less aggressive
buying, and it actually it's actually
turned negative. Then we make a new high
with the red candle with negative delta,
and
when we're making new highs, what we
want to be seeing is
positive delta, positive delta
increasing, but now we are starting to
go down. So, that aggressiveness is kind
of wearing off and that at our high of
the day at this point, we got negative
delta of 373, a red candle, right?
That's a delta order flows delta
divergence, but most importantly, okay,
so I know that aggressive buying is
quieting down. I know aggressive buyers
are not in charge, that aggressive
sellers are in charge. I know I've got
selling at the high of the day.
Aggressive selling, but most
importantly, I've got this three up
here. That is my exhaustion print. All
right? And, you know, on the order flows
trader software, we do have a tool that
will That's why this red line is being
drawn out because if you take a look if
you're using the order flows trader
software, all you got to do, very simple
setting to enable,
is uh you just go down here in the
settings, you'll find uh where is it
here? Exhaustion
print.
Whoops, right here. I got the swing
filter on, so it'll signal me on new
highs or new lows. I got this one set
high for a swing period of 50. Okay, so
it's it's showing me extremely clean
highs and clean lows.
And from that
exhaustion print, right? With
understanding that we are making that
new high
on less aggressive buying, meaning the
aggressive buying is getting weaker as
we're going up into the new highs,
followed by the exhaustion print, put
that together. Aggressive buying, right?
That's what moves the market higher is
that aggressive buying, but if it is
getting weaker, and then the last trader
has bought up here signified with the
three contracts. Only three contracts
traded at that high.
At this moment, we have this nice sell
off. You just get short right here once
this bar closes to confirm that. You
know, it's a move you can see from about
74 25 and a half down to, you know, 74
This is 15 right here. So, it's a quick
3-minute move,
10 points.
Okay? Then we just sort of go sideways,
sort of continuing what we were doing
earlier, right? Remember earlier today
we did have a bit of sideways activity.
Eventually, you know, we did make that
new high. Now again, it's while you do
have the sign of exhaustion coming into
this high, it's not necessarily a move
that's going to last all day long
because this was 9:33 about uh
20 minutes later we did make a new high,
okay? But you know, you got that move.
You got your quick 10 point move here
and then went sideways. Right? It'd be
kind of ridiculous to have a 10 point
move and then it just sort of sit there
10 points in your favor for the next 20
minutes and you not get out because if
this is uh really the high of the day,
we're going to start moving lower, all
right? And as a trader you have to
recognize that when a market is going
sideways,
that's your time to get out, okay? Now,
a little bit later we did make a new
high.
Um like I said, you know, there was
there was some talk coming out of the
Middle East about uh progress being made
in the peace. That's why
we did have this uh
big jump up here. But let me show you
this. We had another exhaustion print
right up here, five, okay? And again, as
we're going up,
all right? You can see the delta 574,
then small 22, 600, okay? New high,
strong positive delta. That's what I
like to see.
Make a new high, small delta minus 12,
another new high, positive delta 279. So
even though we're making these highs,
you know,
it's it's not strongish delta, you know,
this is a negative delta. This one's
279, so it's less than here, but again,
still 279, that's nothing to sneeze at.
Um then we make this new high with the
exhaustion print, right? And we got the
negative delta, so we got this delta
divergence. We got a new high with a
negative delta plus the exhaustion
print.
But okay, this is the big thing here,
understanding
when to get into a trade.
We've identified
exhaustion.
What do we need to happen? We need the
market to start to move down, right? If
this is bearish exhaustion, meaning the
bullish traders are giving up, this bar
here, one of these two bars, I like to
use two bars, has to trade lower than
the low of the bar with exhaustion. This
bar does not, this bar does not, okay?
We're going up. They don't take out this
low. There is no trade here. Even if,
you know, you're you say, "Well, you
know what? I've got my exhaustion. I'm
going to get short anyway."
We did come back up, make one tick high
right here, which would have stopped you
out because, you know, you you got to
put your stop just behind that
exhaustion.
So, either no trade because we didn't go
lower in these next two bars to get you
into the trade, or you're getting
stopped out, which is fine. You know, if
you get stopped out, if you took the
trade early, I don't recommend that. I
always say, "Wait, let the market take
you in." Better to be stopped out. And
this market just sort of went sideways
before, you know, the really the news
really hit the wires that, "Hey, you
know what? We're making some progress in
the Middle East." And then the market
run up here. You know, maybe you would
have got stopped, you know, if you had
your stop here, who knows where you
would got filled, maybe a
point of slippage or something.
Um that was in the S&P's today. You
know, there was
I always say, you know, you always got
to be keeping an eye on on other markets
because, you know, sometimes the market
that you're looking at, there's not a
lot going on. And you know, we live in
this information age, this computer age,
where, you know, we all got computers,
we all got multiple screens, it seems,
so you could have different charts open.
And today in the ultra bonds, there was,
again, you know, a couple of nice trades
here. Um you know, again, you know, for
most of the morning, we were going
sideways in the ultra bonds, you know,
from early in the morning
until about 9:00, when we started going
up. But look at this, right? This yellow
line here, this yellow line is
unchanged. And for most of the morning,
we were trading uh you know, kind of in
between our high of the day and
unchanged. And we get one tick
we sort of make this one tick low right
here from this range that we had been
in.
And it's one tick above
the opening price, which is unchanged.
Okay, so we're coming down, we're
testing unchanged.
Got the exhaustion print of seven.
Next bar trades higher, that's your
entry. We go up, we make a new high.
Okay? Come off a little bit, make new
highs, make new highs, make new highs.
This is a beautiful move from about the
111 20 to 23 area.
A full point up to 112 22, 112 23, where
what? You got a bearish exhaustion print
up here at the high of the day, three
contracts.
Look at that and after that after we
made that high
again, it was interesting because we
just sort of held this high, you know?
This was a sign of a potential
exhaustion. I mean, look as we were
going into this high
positive delta 1800, new high, positive
delta 200
minus 52 at the high, minus 31. We got a
delta divergence with the exhaustion.
This time we just went sideways off this
high. We didn't get a big sell-off or
anything. You know, if you're getting
short, you're getting short right here,
and it just comes back up, test the high
test the high, doesn't stop you out cuz
your stop is just one tick above that
high. You know, and it just sort of
hangs around there
a little bit against you, a little bit
for you.
And you know, right now, where are we
here? Let's take a look.
Uh just a little bit lower, you know, or
112 22. So, basically
you know, right around break even. But
again, you know, if you're getting short
at at 10:17 and it's 11:00 10 or 30
minutes later, an hour later, and it's
just right around your your entry. Just
get out. You know, I I wouldn't say get
You would have gotten short here at
10:17. You got to hold it until 2:00 in
the afternoon.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> You're just better getting out and
looking for, um, you know, another trade
in another market, potentially.
Um, what was interesting about this
reversal down here, as well, taking a
look at the delta.
-194 here, -478 here, -583 here.
Okay?
And look at that. I mean, even here
earlier, -741, -669. So, -700, -1400,
-1800, 2200,
you know, -2700. I'm just doing rough
math here. And this market can't sell
off. Consistent selling from, basically,
8:25 until about 9:15, and we can't go
lower. It is just strong negative delta
each bar here, here, here, here, here.
And we can't push lower.
And then we do try to break lower. We
take out this low right here by, what?
One tick.
Okay? Finally, we broke down and we made
a new low.
But what you got? Seven.
Where's my traders? Where's my strong
negative delta? It's not there. Traders
aren't interested in pushing this any
lower. That's what exhaustion is.
Is when traders don't want to move the
market
any further, either for, you know, they
they they have no more selling to do or
no more buying to do, in this case,
selling, since it's trying to go lower.
They got no more selling to do.
Once you've removed that selling from
the market, that pressure from the
market, because just look at this, even
in the delta, right? Here,
the min deltas -700, -741, 658, 615.
is just minus 52.
Where are my sellers? They're not there.
And it comes back with strong aggressive
buying to trade back into that area that
we had just been trading at before we
finally break out and run up another
full point right off of this. This is
your catalyst bar.
All right, so you know
again, you know, I I I make these videos
because I I I want to show you
how simple it is, right? It's It's not
about stacking all these different
indicators on the different time frames
looking Oh, I got to look on a 4-hour
time frame then a 1-hour then a
15-minute then a 1-minute. No, I'm just
looking at a simple chart, one chart,
right? The footprint chart is showing me
and nay, I take that back. It's
screaming at me the answer
that exhaustion is right there. If you
know what to look for, if you know where
to identify it.
All right, so thanks for watching this
video
and I'll see you guys on my next video.